marisa rosas de zaragoza tú estás
nominada al premio charles bildu que se
va a entregar aproximadamente quería
preguntarte de qué se trata este premio
por qué estás nominada y qué se trata
para ti qué valor tiene para ti el mismo
bueno antes que nada luis agradecerte la
invitación la oportunidad de compartir
el trabajo que estamos realizando desde
montreal y si efectivamente esta
nominación es un es una gran noticia en
medio de tantas noticias difíciles que
estamos recibiendo todos en general con
esta realidad de la pandemia y es un
premio que existe desde ya desde hace
algunos años que se otorga a personas
que tienen una trayectoria en el medio
cultural que es significativa el
gobierno local el gobierno provincial y
el organismo cultura para todos culto
por tus ese es el organizador y hay dos
categorías un boleto internacional una
categoría internacional y otra
provincial en este caso mi nominación
fue propuesta por el organismo que
trabaja aquí desde hace tiempo tema de
temas cercanos al arte latinoamericano
que es latín arte que seguramente
conoces aquí en montreal y también por
el cívica que es el centro de
investigaciones internacionales sobre
estudios afro canadienses y caribeños y
entonces a partir de estos dos
organismos con los que he trabajado se
propuso esta nominación al premio vito y
estoy muy contenta porque en realidad lo
que propone este premio es un
reconocimiento a la trayectoria y el
aporte de
los inmigrantes a la escena cultural y
artística la idea es encontrar modelos
inspiran tests inspiradores para que
pues se muestre un ejemplo concreto la
integración de otros horizontes
culturales aquí en el paisaje en
montreal en sí ahora decir es difícil
encuadrar te porque tu actividad abarca
tantas facetas que es muy difícil poner
un rótulo pero podríamos hablar de ti
como un artista visual o al menos tu
trayectoria lo indica se define como
artista visual investigadora y mediadora
cultural y con mucha participación con
mucha presencia con mucho
trayectoria en lo que son las sociedades
y el arte en las sociedades
interculturales y el arte latino que ve
que se cristo me interesó mucho existe
un arte latino que pensé yo yo te diría
que desde son términos siempre
problemáticos sabremos el término
latinoamericano es una invención también
en fin
este hay hay mucho de que trabajar en
estos términos para descolonizar los
pero en términos generales yo te diría
que más que ponerle una etiqueta y poner
un nombre específico y etiquetarlo a los
artistas y sus prácticas a mí lo que me
interesa va a subrayar y en eso he
trabajado desde hace consistentemente
desde hace por lo menos diez años que
estoy aquí en montreal en la reescritura
de la historia en insertar nuevos
imaginarios en un paisaje cultural y en
ese sentido yo quería especificar con
esta denominación el latino quebequense
el aporte de artistas que vienen de
américa latina' de diferentes horizontes
latinoamericanos que se instalan
efectivamente en este territorio que es
muy particular que es que ve con una
historia propia y con unos debates
internos muy particulares y quería como
o más que saber si existe o no y poner
una etiqueta porque justamente hay que
trabajar en de reconstruir estas
nociones básicamente era para mirar una
especificidad y una minoría dentro de
otra minoría en este sentido me
interesaba pensar en cómo hay si formas
estratégicas de crear discursos que
devienen formas de mirar el mundo en
contexto que viene de américa latina y
que se instala que que tiene un diálogo
muy particular y un color en el contexto
y en la ecología que ve que en ese
entonces para resumir existe yo creo que
existe no es único hay muchas formas
cada artista tiene estrategias
diferentes
que estamos evolucionando constantemente
entonces existe pero atomizado en muchas
prácticas tablas de reescribir y cuál
sería la línea principal de esta
reescritura por donde pasaría a mí me
parece que hay que trabajar en la
reescritura de las prácticas artísticas
que nos han sido reflejadas o incluidas
en una red en un medio que tiene cierto
cierto discurso oficial por así decirlo
que no integra e integra otras voces la
reescritura empieza por empezar a
nombrarlas empezar a señalar las empezar
a mostrar sus particularidades su color
su riqueza y en ese sentido empezar a
integrarlas en el imaginario en el en
esta escena cultural quebequense
entonces la reescritura sería hacer
exposiciones explicar
de alguna manera conectar estos
discursos en un imaginario colectivo ver
cómo se están sumando estas voces y mi
trabajo efectivamente si bien tiene
fases muy diferenciadas entre la
investigación la la la parte de
mediación y la parte de curaduría para
mí es un todo orgánico en el sentido mi
oficio es de integrar e integrar nuevas
voces integrar nuevos discursos integrar
nuevas interpretaciones entonces desde
ese lado yo diría que estoy participando
a una reescritura de la historia
artistas que muy probablemente nos
hubieran conocido presentarnos y
mostrarlos desde
una escena más oficial por así decirlo
entonces no sé si eso puede aclarar un
poco trabajo desde luego y en este año
de pandemia en el que todos hemos visto
nuestras vidas alteradas de alguna
manera modificadas por lo menos hay
actividades tuyas que están pendientes
de cristalización o de una mayor
difusión por decirlo de esa manera una
de esas actividades tiene que ver con la
creación femenina intercultural puedes
aclararnos de qué se trata si es una
dentro de esa voluntad de sumar voces
distintas y actores que por supuesto no
soy la única están en el aire de
nuestros tiempos y me interesa mucho la
voz particular que tenemos y la mirada
que tenemos también las mujeres y
sabemos que tenemos dificultades
muy particulares de género en ese
sentido saber qué bueno tenemos mucho
que lidiar con él con la tradición y la
noción de ser madres profesionistas en
fin y el tema de la pandemia ha
demostrado con datos duros desde
diferentes estudios sociales que a las
mujeres se les ha cargado la mano del
trabajo y la carga es muy muy difícil
entonces para muchas es difícil
continuar sus prácticas laborales
creativas en fin mercado de trabajo
entonces en ese sentido se ha suspendido
un poco pero tengo proyectos muy
puntuales en los que colaboró como por
ejemplo el proyecto entre el entre ellas
que es un proyecto que va directamente a
trabajar con la comunidad grupos de
mujeres que en este momento están siendo
vulnerados vulnerables y a partir de de
diferentes territorios específicos como
en el caso del barrio de sant leonard
ahí vamos estamos haciendo pequeños
grupos muy reducidos
decidimos no ponerlo en pausa
vamos a continuar con pequeños grupos de
34 personas cuatro mujeres que vamos a
vincularnos en un proyecto de creación
colectiva en este caso es un patchwork
un cortar point como le llaman acá
trabajo textil para hacer vínculos
interculturales pero también para salir
de la soledad y de todos estos retos que
estamos viviendo todas entonces en eso
es por un lado de trabajo comunitario y
por otro lado también pensar en que
queremos seguir trabajando con las voces
de las mujeres de las artistas y
poniendo siempre integrando su voz en
todos los proyectos que realizamos como
nos sigue el público de otras latitudes
de canadá y de fuera de canal también
vamos a aclarar que el barrio de sanyo
nar es uno de los barrios que componen
la ciudad de montreal donde tú te
encuentras en este momento pero ese
accionar artístico excede incluso a la
sociedad un monte alguien se va mucho
más allá de la ciudad puede ser desafío
principal al que tú personalmente como
artista de vista enfrentarte
en este 2020 tan complicado
yo creo que como todos los artistas
hemos estado muy olvidados por los
grandes proyectos de gobiernos y de
apoyo si bien han sido proyectos que se
dan al sector cultural los gobiernos por
ejemplo y beneficiando me de esto que
acabas de decir que no solamente están
observando nosotros moviéndonos en
montreal en canadá todos los gobiernos
de alguna manera mandaron paquetes
económicos al sector artístico pero uno
de los grandes problemas que yo
encuentro es que se quedan en las
instituciones y en los grandes actores
muchas veces no llega a los creadores de
aquí a los pequeños artistas que estaban
trabajando su proyecto y su concierto su
exposición y que de repente se
encontraron sin una entrada sin ningún
trabajo entonces creo que ese es el
mayor reto que llegue
este apoyo a los actores que están
produciendo se queda siempre los grandes
nombres en las grandes instituciones y
no está llegando a todos en el sentido
demasiado difícil como a todos soy
trabajadora autónoma también y eso es un
reto que en el que todos estamos
reinventando nos realiza este mes de
octubre es el mes de la herencia hispana
con quién tú estás ligado además por
supuesto qué significa para ti la
herencia hispana aquí en quebec
pues yo diría que bueno antes que nada
para mí ha sido siempre un orgullo venir
de mexico en particular pero también
identificarme con una red de culturas en
latinoamerica y con un idioma es mi
idioma hispano español este me parece
que hay mucho que celebrar hay mucho que
celebrar y que reconocer del color del
aporte que tienen estas voces hispanas
en en quebec y en montreal
específicamente porque hay un gran
público interesado por saber curioso de
saber que lo que está produciendo en
américa latina en muchos contactos
históricos hay mucho entusiasmo por
saber que se está siendo hay una gran
presencia
de población que viene de estos países
hay un gran intercambio un flujo de
intercambio es constante y para mí
significa poner en evidencia y
visibilizar este este aporte tan rico y
cultural y me parece que es una buena
manera de demostrar como siempre que los
intercambios interculturales van a hacer
siempre productivos si reconocemos
nuestros nuestros contactos nuestras
nuestros valores y que los ponemos en
contribución a la sociedad y hay un
diálogo horizontal y productivo creo que
eso es lo que más me entusiasma de este
mes esta visión es visibilización y
hablando de la comunidad hispana es una
comunidad minoritaria y como toda la
minoría tiene sus inconvenientes también
y relacionado con el tema de las
minorías en los últimos tiempos se ha
hablado mucho de la cuestión del racismo
que es un tema en el que tú también has
trabajado
con este punto de vista y racismo aquí
en quebec y en general yo creo que
siempre es un tema muy sensible y hay
que tocarlo con gran apertura y empatía
y yo creo que el debate tiene que
reconocer que si hablamos desde la
historia y desde la colonización tenemos
que reconocer que si hay un racismo
sistémico que muchas veces es
imperceptible que muchas veces es
inconsciente pero que está ahí y que nos
diferencia entonces de muchas maneras yo
habla del mercado de trabajo hay datos
duros que hablan de que específicamente
los
ciudadanos o inmigrantes o la gente que
se va incorporando de diferentes
horizontes culturales tiene muchísima
más dificultad de tener un trabajo
estable y tener un ingreso significativo
entonces eso habla concretamente de que
todavía hay racismo sistémico
yo creo que que si bien muchas veces es
un reflejo hay que abordarlo desde desde
nombrarlo y de trabajarlo entonces a mí
me parece que es uno de los grandes
temas del general del del mundo
actual y que no podemos sobrepasar esta
etapa si no lo afrontamos lo nombramos y
más allá de señalar culpables o víctimas
todos intervenimos desde una voz mucho
más productiva
marisa temas pendientes hay un montón
pero nos vamos a seguir extendiendo y
demasiado eres una conocida del radio
canadá internacional nuestro público ya
ha podido verte incluso en nuestra
emisión de los viernes que esperamos
retomar en el futuro y te volveríamos a
invitar para la ocasión también te
agradezco este contacto con nosotros te
deseo lo mejor para
premio y esperamos novedades entonces a
corto plazo cuando tú las tengas
muchísimas gracias muchas gracias y un
saludo para toda la gente en américa
latina y donde no se escuche